[Music]
we're gonna
reckless abandon accordion running keep
your head up and focus on a single point
on the horizon while running
your back will thank you that is a sign
on a door
also do you want murdered because
walking into a house with a keep outside
on the door is how you get yourself
murdered
dear heavenly squirrel lord please help
the digestive passageways of this highly
confused underwater dwelling creature
the lack of chewing and the alarming
consistency of this food chunk may end
her too
soon not knowing how to capitalize the
letter i so do not
disturb that means you spongebob
sandy knew that there was a high
probability of someone disturbing her
gnarly squirrely slumber
so why not lock the doors no
means yes i mean we like to think the
patrick and spongebob are great
but patrick is a total [ __ ] here and
spongebob is going along with something
he knows to be wrong
it's okay spongebob this stuff is
water i'm sitting myself for believing
that i could ever understand how any of
this works
also sponges need salt water to survive
and even if sandy's house is somehow
creating saltwater snow here there's not
nearly enough to keep bob's holes from
filling up with air that will eventually
kill him
will no one think of bob's holes also
also starfish too
patrick's dead now too hibernation must
mean the opposite of beauty sleep
gotta say when i turned on spongebob
today i wasn't expecting overt and
callous fat shaming but
life throws you curves sometimes sandy
manages to get some rest in between the
shenanigans and i cannot figure out how
she can sleep when the entire room is
brighter than the outdoors
where is the light source in this house
or in this enclosed sandy terrarium
sleeping on a pillow that's at this
steep of an angle will really pick up
your spine folks
look into a chiropractic certified
option and get a full night's rest
the sin is not sponsored hi there
spongebob
back talking hey sandy if you can't hear
us
don't say anything are we supposed to
actively despise spongebob and patrick
because they're being such sponge holes
that they can eat a bag of sea cucumbers
for all i care
also it's been a very long time since
they've been out of the snow and
therefore
water not that any of that matters but
the show set it up so it's my job to
tear it down
all right pinhead your time is up
cowboy cultural appropriation cultural
appropriation
i say i'm dirty dan i'm dirty dad
for the love of my sanity you both can
be dirty dan
now stop hitting each other with
impossible snow creations without gloves
on frostbite is no joke
[Music]
scalpers because spongebob can create
tape out of thin air but not wood for a
fire
or just a fire maybe it's her fur the
random way this show google image
searches itself is so strange
thanks spongebob i always wondered what
fur meant sponge i'm a big man
a big big man thinking size matters
first here's a scene for sandy somehow
not noticing this when she is clearly
changed out of her hibernation pjs
already
and second we all understand that this
means spongebob and patrick clearly
removed her clothing while she was
sleeping to reach all these places
like full-on stripped her down a duct
tape waxter without asking permission
kid shows man they dark
i'm not hooting us bob team wildcat in
the west oh you're nothing but pure evil
like it's the fruits of the devil
hi there spongebob
now open your mind to me please
i'm gonna rip your arms off
flap jacks too early for flapjacks
does it spring yet i don't know don't
feel my balls and tell me
i've been locking up nice box all day
no kelly clarkson